botanique de Montréal, est
avec nous. M. Joly, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- D'abord, question de base
parce qu'on va arriver à
la question qui m'a fasciné,
mais question de base :
rappelez- nous pourquoi
les feuilles des arbres
changent de couleur.
SIMON JOLY, botaniste,
Jardin botanique de Montréal
- En fait, ce qu'on observe
à l'automne, c'est un peu
une programmation d'une mort
programmée de la part des
arbres. Donc, quand les arbres
réalisent que la longueur
des jours diminue, ils savent
que la fin de la saison approche
et ils vont progressivement
mourir. Mais donc, avant
de mourir, ils vont dégrader
la chlorophylle afin, entre
autres, de pouvoir récupérer
certains nutriments qui sont
précieux pour la plante.
Donc, ce qu'on voit, c'est
une perte globalement de
la chlorophylle, ce pigment
qui reflète le vert, ce qui fait
que les feuilles sont vertes.
Et en se dégradant,
la chlorophylle va révéler
d'autres pigments qui sont
présents dans les feuilles,
notamment les pigments jaunes
et les pigments rouges.
- Bon! Mais... mais ce que
j'entendais, c'est que le jaune,
ça s'explique bien. Comme vous
dites, c'est l'absence du vert.
Le vert s'en va; le jaune
apparaît. Mais que le rouge
rouge et certaines essences,
comme les érables, produisent
du rouge, mais pourquoi
un érable dépenserait de
l'énergie pour produire du rouge
alors que la feuille va mourir
dans quelques semaines?
- Oui, vous avez raison.
Donc, les pigments rouges sont
un peu particuliers parce
qu'eux sont générés, sont
produits à l'automne. Donc,
c'est un peu une combinaison
d'une perte du vert et d'un gain
de rouge qui permet d'avoir
des feuilles rouges.
Eh oui, les plantes vont
produire des pigments rouges.
Je dirais qu'on n'a pas eu un
consensus au niveau scientifique
sur la vraie raison de la
présence des pigments rouges,
mais on a quand même une bonne
idée. Donc, une de ces raisons,
c'est qu'on pense que
les pigments rouges pourraient
servir à protéger les feuilles,
protéger notamment des
radiations solaires qui sont
importantes. Donc, on sait,
en fait, que la lumière,
ça peut être très dommageable
pour les organismes vivants.
C'est pour ça que, nous,
les humains, on a de la mélamine
sur notre peau qui nous protège
des rayons UV. Et pendant
toute la saison de croissance,
bien, la chlorophylle sert
à capter beaucoup de
ces particules de lumière
qui protègent la feuille.
Mais quand il n'y a plus
de chlorophylle, bien,
qu'est-ce qui arrive?
C'est que la feuille peut être
endommagée par la lumière.
Et donc, une des hypothèses
principales pour ces pigments
rouges, c'est que les pigments
rouges vont aller capter
la lumière et donc protéger
la feuille, et donc permettre
à la feuille de réabsorber
tous ces nutriments à l'automne,
qui permet de les stocker
dans ses racines, par exemple,
pour la prochaine saison
de croissance.
- OK, parce que je lisais que
ça peut que ça pouvait aussi
être pour se protéger d'insectes
et tout ça, qu'il y avait eu
un mystère autour.
Parce qu'encore une fois,
l'arbre produit, dépense
de l'énergie pour le rouge,
ce qui n'est pas le cas
pour le jaune.
- Non, effectivement. Donc, ça,
c'était l'hypothèse qui est
peut-être la plus supportée,
celle de se protéger contre
les rayons du soleil.
Mais c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi
beaucoup de chercheurs qui ont
proposé que le rouge pouvait
aussi être une raison de
se protéger des insectes.
En gros, ce que les gens
proposaient, c'est que c'est
un signal qui suggère
aux insectes que ces arbres-là
sont pas intéressants pour eux,
et donc ils vont les éviter.
Et effectivement, il y a
certains groupes de plantes
pour lesquels on a trouvé
ce comportement d'insectes.
Particulièrement, par exemple,
un des exemples, c'est
les pucerons. Donc, les pucerons
vont migrer vers les arbres
à l'automne et ils vont
être présents au printemps.
Et donc, si les arbres arrivent
à éviter ou à repousser
les pucerons, bien, il va avoir
un gain au niveau du printemps.
- Simon Joly, on va se coucher
plus instruits. Merci. Botaniste
au Jardin botanique de Montréal.
Merci, monsieur Joly.
- Ça me fait plaisir. A